the facts concerning the incident cannot
be made public in any way shape or form
why is that do you think is it because
the aliens all of the horrifying aliens
with the shadow bodies and they're
probably standing directly behind me or
you miss okay this is this what does
this lead okay
I can't move okay okay
go come on yeah bye supposed to be dead
how about a cap odd booth
I have no eyes okay well we don't want
to keep talking about your personal
problems let's just get back to the main
thing here Sean Bean booth that's how
good sounds
that's very bad sounds I see you over
there I see you see you here in the
woods just waiting for me to go over
there
I probably shouldn't just be standing
out of your eyes got a gorge a wooden I
realize he was a spotting me Oh into the
forest of death
Oh exactly where I wanted to be great
well am i oh no I'll be okay oh god oh
god oh oh oh God ah Jesus Christ
okay that's a good place to stop I guess
where's this lead I don't know is this
lead it's just Heidi hold and not die in
or is it a hidey hole they specifically
made the Diane this is the death hole I
went into the death hole yep the
whimpering is suited I am dying